casas convertidas en montañas de
escombros eso fue lo que pudo constatar
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
en su viaje que el tópix de dawson
sprints el estado más afectado por un
enjambre de tornados que azotó el sur y
al este de la unión americana el viernes
bailén ofreció ayuda a los damnificados
por lo que anunció que el gobierno
cubrirá el 100 por ciento de los costos
durante los primeros 30 días de todo el
trabajo de emergencia
tengo una intención de hacer lo que sea
necesario durante el tiempo que sea
necesario para apoyar a su estado a sus
líderes locales mientras se recupera y
se reconstruir porque se recuperará y se
reconstruirá
212 que ya sabe el alcance y la escala
de esa destrucción es casi increíble
somos un tambo live los residentes de
mayfield se sintieron complacidos por la
visita de biden
apreciamos que el presidente venga ya
sabes
sí no ciertamente no somos el único
lugar que ha sido devastado pero el
hecho de que venga aquí significa mucho
por el momento las autoridades locales
asisten a los centenares de personas que
resultaron afectadas con dotación de
implementos de emergencia agua potable y
cobijas para afrontar el frío mientras
que los meteorólogos advierten que más
tornados podrían estar en camino